um but tell me about your new movie
since you're here oh no problem
well i'm sure people paying will be
paying attention to what i'm saying as
we hold the cutest animals on the planet
uh it's called happily yeah and it's
about a um
happily married couple uh for 14 years
who uh and this is the jumping off point
of the movie um
we uh can't we act like newlyweds still
we
um we have sex all the time so
and our and our friends hate us there
there we are in the bathroom
at a friend's house and someone's trying
to get in that's carrie boucher
she's one of the best actors i've ever
worked with it's directed by ben david
grabinsky and
um it is uh it's like a it's like an
episode of twilight zone
with a lot of sex it's also relationship
goals
i think yeah yeah it's not bad so there
are a lot of sexy scenes so
how does your wife feel yeah why don't
you show a clip what the heck
we did we didn't we just showed the one
where she's killing someone in the
background
oh perfect uh no how does your wife feel
about that well it's funny when people
like how does your wife feel
and no one ever goes because i've been
in a bunch of movies where i get killed
yeah and like tortured no one ever's
like how did she feel about that they
don't even ask about that so
uh i always like like here's the deal
and
the uh she was like she really liked the
message and
um we're not gonna watch it with the
kids no uh
but uh but uh that's why i married the
coolest person on the planet my wife
sarah's like
i don't know what i would be i would be
in this cage if i yeah
i think there she is right there i think
you keep bringing things home that can
go in cages like you keep and she said
if you bring one more animal home
i did yes i she said if i brought one
more dog home that might be the end
that would that would tip it we uh we
are gonna be married for 25 years this
july five years that's amazing yeah
where did y'all meet i don't know i
don't remember it was a long time ago
it was like a boy i don't even know her
middle name yeah we met at a kelly
clarkson concert
25 years ago it was a dinner theater
thing it was
cool you had a junior high yeah you were
like seven or eight it was
you're still fabulous thank you thank
you uh we sat with simon cowell
yeah because i knew him when i was a kid
yeah he was super fun
told us about his face looked exactly
the same
t-shirt yeah a black t-shirt a little
bit of chest hair popping out
uh my wife and i met on a movie set in
seattle
and her mom was an extra and her brother
was a production assistant and they
uh i was introduced to her i knew who
she was because she dated
no one and uh so then i we had a mutual
friend and i called my friend i was like
hey do you think sarah williams
will uh go out with me and my friend was
like
no and uh i got her number and i
uh wore her down i wore her down why why
do you think she didn't date anyone
she's just not interested
yeah i mean she was like wait is there a
guy out there with bunnies
and a basketball jersey and five
thousand dogs yeah uh yeah i'm not
saying she has the greatest judgment on
the planet
uh but she has somehow she has agreed to
be married to me for 25 years that's
amazing
yeah no it's it's great we got divorced
three times and got remarried
someone started clapping i was like wait
what uh
no but as you know i have seven wives so
yeah
yeah let's start that rumor yep i'm
still here just waiting for you to
subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever